here we go okay so the morning of
January 24 we started talking about
about the women's March and how
incredible it was that they had managed
to pull off this global movement that
was just like a phenomenon could if i
grasp like the logistics of how anyone
could make that how any group could make
that happen and then I said you know oh
but I would totally throw down for
science March we should organize that my
exact words were I can tell you seems
like it would be pretty easy to be
honest just reach out to academics at
local universities which is like the
most spectacularly ignorant statement um
yeah seems like it would be pretty easy
as like this like this will be on my
tombstone so I emailed the person who
had the twitter handle who's Jonathan
Berman one of the other co-chairs and
started emailing with him saying I
wanted to tie everything together and
then in the midst of us having that kind
of email conversation it exploded on
Twitter and went to from like you know
whatever it was like 10 50 followers to
like 30,000 and it just kept growing and
growing and growing and and it was kind
of so dramatic that there was really no
other choice but to like throw in I
happen to be off that morning which is
the only reason that I'm talking to you
now instead of one of the other like
hundreds of people who had this idea my
name is Caroline why become one of the
National co-chairs for the marks for
science the March for science is a
global movement that focuses on the role
of science and society and the
importance of having it inform the
policy that shapes our present and
future there's 70 people in the core
national group all volunteers no one's
getting paid no one has asked to be paid
it's just people dedicating their time
because they're passionate about what
the march stands for and we have I think
like 150 some odd partners now and then
there's the satellite cities which we
just cross 490 satellite cities globally
it's a lot of a lot of moving parts that
we're trying to keep together all really
remotely over the internet really just
trying to pull everyone together and to
make sure that everything kind of gels
it is the same place come april 20
seconds have you guys haven't met right
nice to meet you her hair was not purple
pink in real life my name is ayanna
elizabeth johnson and i am co-director
of partnerships for the marked for
science I'm a scientist I am a marine
biologist by training so I really care
about science because it's it's kind of
like the way my brain works in a really
foundational way that I interact with
the world I was just chatting with my
mom last weekend who was a civil rights
activist both my parents were and they
were joking that we finally got their
daughter to be an activist but it's for
science which was not really what anyone
expected would be necessary my name is
Courtney Weber and i am the social media
co-lead afford the march for science
there its life we've had a hundred four
people donate just this week which is
really great and then I just like how
much people are still interacting with
posts I always worried for however many
posts we get out that we're going to
eventually overwhelm people but they're
still very much interactive and engaged
so I got these buttons in the mail today
and I showed the mailman the buttons and
he said wow those are really cool can I
have one and I said well it's for the
March for science do you know what that
is he said no and I said it's about
facts in support of facts and evidence
based policy making and the role of
science and government and society and
he said yeah yeah I'm super for fact I
mean that sounds great and I said well
you can have one if you're going to
march so we'll see hopefully he'll be
there day of march i will be sharing the
really cool things that are happening we
really focused on people with like
strong history of speaking out about
science though bill nye is the science
communicator making it accessible lydia
is a really amazing example of like more
basic publicly funded research that can
change the entire course of medicine and
the lives of millions with diabetes and
then dr. mona who can speak about
government attempts to silence science
and the importance of citizen science
and those together as a unit they
represent everything the march stands
for there's a power to kind of standing
in a crowd with people who are standing
behind the same thing that you are and
I'm hoping that that's what the march
does it sends that
a message like you're not alone this is
something that we're all going to work
on together and that is a really
powerful thing so it's not necessarily
april twenty second it's what everyone
does when they walk away the know the
association of american physicians just
voted over eighty-three percent of them
voted to have a sponsor and endorsed
Marco science so many amazing cigarettes
that work